make sure that your company is testing
your product or service on a small scale
before you dump a ton of money into it
because if you make the wrong move you
could be in debt for the rest of your
life trying to pay off this one bad
business decision hi I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe that hungry entrepreneurs
deserve help and today mention the
question from a YouTube viewer mo one of
my new fans on facebook and and on
YouTube answering tons of questions so I
love mo thank you for participating Mo's
question is my goal is to sell hair
products online through up-and-coming
hair lines that haven't hit mainstream
how do i tested to see if I could sell
online if I don't invest in the product
itself to sell do I buy a little bit of
each and see if it sells even a little
bit of each would end up costing a lot
somo a couple options here for you I
would not recommend spending money on
buying inventory and then hoping that
they sell online this is the classic
mistake that most entrepreneurs make
they think they have a great idea for a
product or service especially on the
product side either they're going to
invent it themselves they're going to be
a supplier and sell and you end up
buying all this product and it sits in
your basement in your garage or in your
bedroom and it doesn't sell and you're
stuck with this inventory having dumped
thousands of dollars into it and you
never get that money back and you end up
chucking it or selling at a huge
discount and I don't want that for you
what you have to do is test if you're
launching a new product if you're
representing the company I would try to
set up a website if you're trying to do
this online set it up and be a
commissioned sales person don't buy the
product make sure the company can
fulfill it and if they can't do it if
you're working with the wrong company
then find the company that will do that
we're all you're doing is facilitating
the order and you don't actually have to
have any products talk to the company's
if they're just getting started up say
you want to be an online division for
them you want to set up a website to rub
some of their stuff if I make a sale can
you deliver so all you're doing is
feeding sales to them and they're
sending it to the customer that's a way
for you to test it if you set up this
website put all this energy in the
credit amazing website have tons of
a Content testimonials all that stuff
and it doesn't sell then the moisture
out is just that website you don't have
two thousand a product X sitting in your
bedroom with thousands of dollars sunk
into that then you're out of okay that's
the first thing the second thing you can
do if you're creating your own product
line is launched a website talk about it
and try to get some pre-sales try to get
pre-orders for what you're doing talk
about the benefits of your product you
can show pictures of it you can show
what the what people can expect from
using it share your story why you
invented this and try to get people to
buy before you've actually created the
product if there is an interest if
people are asking for the same yes I
need this please make this product and
you get to a certain number whatever
makes sense maybe you need 10 maybe 50
maybe 100 whatever it is that makes
sense for your business then you can
make it then you know that your idea is
good if you create the site talk about
how great your product is you're
promoting it people hit the site and
nobody signs up there's no interest then
you've just saved yourself thousands of
dollars going in the wrong direction the
other thing you can look at if you're
just starting that will help with your
pre-sales is web sites like Kickstarter
Kickstarter is designed to help
entrepreneurs launch their products you
put your idea up there and it's
basically a website that helps
facilitate priora pre-orders pre-sales
you say when it's going to be delivered
you say all the great features about it
and people will start to buy and you
have to reach your goal you know if you
reach your goal your funding limit then
you have the money you need to launch
and if you don't you can cancel the
project and it will help you test to see
is this something that people want or
not and your worst case scenario there
is you're out your time in creating the
campaign but you're not out thousands of
dollars in inventory that you end up
again in your basement in your garage
you can't sell it okay too many
entrepreneurs make that mistake don't
buy product don't buy inventory until
you have some sales coming in and you
have a pretty good bet that is going to
work because no matter how excited you
get about it no matter how much you love
the product it's not a guarantee that
other people are going to love it as
well and I
don't want you to end up with all this
inventory and you're not able to sell it
and make your money back thanks to the
question for those are you watching you
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up below it makes me want to do more for
you and hey I want to hear from you to
please leave a comment under this video
let me know what you think about this
question that mo ass and if you have a
question for your own business leave it
in the comments I'll do my best to
create a video reply for you and we'll
see where things go so thank you guys
and I'll see you on the next episode